this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the ad-free creator controlled
streaming service when you sign up for
curiosity stream with the link below
[Music]
with the transition from team red
powerful old guy to team blue powerful
old guy
a number of important topics have
returned to the forefront of the
american consciousness
one of the most important issues as is
the case in any country is healthcare
while other developed nations and even
many far less developed nations
enjoy less expensive healthcare with
better outcomes than the us
american citizens are on the brink of
disaster now more than ever
in this episode we're going to talk
about the absurd cost of prescription
drugs and why a life-saving medicine in
the u.s can cost hundreds of times more
than in other countries
how did the drug improve if i were to
look at a pill and analyze it from 2005
when it cost 215
and i was looked today at when it cost
763 would that pill be the same
i understand your question about the
pill the pill the manufacturing for it
would be the same great thank you i want
to turn to one other number if you would
you would help me um
do you know what this number is
i does it ring any bells i
i think you're referring to my
compensation in some way
in some way this was your compensation
in 2017
for being ceo of celgene and that's a
lot of money any increase in the price
of revlimid would also
increase your bonus by increasing
earnings
isn't that right mr ellis if revenues
increased
and expenses did not then earnings would
be enhanced
thank you in fact you personally
received half
of them half a million dollars
personally just by tripling the price of
revlimid
so to recap here the drug didn't get any
better
the cancer patients didn't get any
better you
just got better at making money you just
refined your skills at price gouging
what you just saw was representative
katie porter grilling mark alice the
former ceo of pharma company
gene over massive price hikes on their
cancer drug revlimid
the executive admitted that despite the
huge added cost to patients the drug was
fundamentally unchanged
it didn't work better or faster there
had been no improvements to
effectiveness
it was exactly the same product and yet
the price for a single pill had jumped
from 215 dollars
already very expensive to 763 dollars
where did this extra money go straight
into executive pockets
alice who was already paid 13 million
dollars per year
netted an extra 500 000 simply for
raising the price of a single drug
this particular exchange went viral back
in 2020 but the despicable practice of
medical price gouging is far more
widespread than this single example
in fact it's standard american operating
procedure before we get into the
specifics
let's look at a few basic facts about
the american healthcare industry as a
whole
the u.s spends more money per capita on
healthcare than any other nation on
earth
you would assume that this expenditure
would guarantee the best care in the
world
that is not the case despite being the
most expensive healthcare system on
earth
consuming over 16 percent of our gdp
it's one of if not the least effective
in the developed world
we spend over ten thousand dollars per
capita on health care
and not only is the quality of care
subpar we don't even come close to
covering everybody
compare this to places like germany who
paid drastically less per capita and
guarantee coverage to all citizens
there were over 27 million uninsured
americans in 2018
and that number will have skyrocketed in
the last year thanks to millions of
coveted layoffs across the country
even before the pandemic we had more
uninsured and underinsured citizens than
any other developed nation
in addition to not covering a large
portion of the population even those
with excellent health insurance
by american standards that is struggle
to pay medical bills
over 25 percent of insured people
reported having difficulty paying for
the exorbitant cost of their treatment
of this group 63 had to pay most or all
of their savings to cover the medical
bills
and 42 percent had to find a second job
life-saving drugs in america often cost
10 times what they cost in other
countries
for example in canada one vial of
insulin cost 32
in the united states the same drug from
the same factory
costs 300 and that's not even an extreme
example
take the hiv drug truvada in australia
it cost just eight dollars
in the u.s it cost two thousand dollars
despite u.s taxpayers footing the bill
for its development
every year over half a million people go
bankrupt trying to pay their medical
bills
in a country where 40 of the population
can't afford a surprise 400
expense an ambulance ride to the
hospital will cost you more than twice
that amount
and all of this is happening in the
richest country on earth
this all sounds pretty bad right it is
of all the things americans choose to
defend our sadistic healthcare industry
should not be one of them
it's inhumane ineffective and deeply
corrupt if you're wondering why our
system is so awful
just follow the money the healthcare
industry spends more money on lobbying
than the oil and defense industries
combined
and those are both massive lobbies
lobbying of course is just a euphemism
for bribery
lobbyists make generous donations to
politicians those politicians pocket the
money and write legislation that favors
the donors industry
they both make money and average
americans are worse off than they were
before
this cycle continues indefinitely and
features a ludicrous revolving door
wherein politicians often go on to
become lobbyists themselves
it's a twisted charade and bears no
semblance to actual democracy
but why are pharmaceuticals so lucrative
there are several reasons
one of them the fact that the
relationship between manufacturers
insurance companies hospitals and
middlemen
is so convoluted that it's incredibly
difficult to nail down when any one of
them is price gouging
but beyond that it's just simple math
nearly half of all americans take
prescription drugs
that's almost 165 million people and it
represents a massive market for
pharmaceuticals
it's especially lucrative because many
people require these drugs just to stay
alive
so they'll pay whatever they have to
let's take perhaps the most common
example
insulin there are roughly 23 million
diabetics in the u.s
and if we expand that category to people
who are pre-diabetic
the number shoots up to 100 million
people nearly a third of the total u.s
population
when someone has diabetes they rely on
insulin it's not optional
the average diabetic needs somewhere
around two to three vials of insulin per
month though some people require much
more
in the range of four to six vials given
the price of insulin in this country
the monthly cost is just too much for
many people to afford
all right so i gotta i got a serious
question for everybody out there
i generally want to know this okay
how how is everybody making it how
i'm like i've worked i've worked for
like 17 years i i work all the time
i've been paying medical bills on my son
for nine years since he was born
and he was just diagnosed with type 1
diabetes and it has to have
insulin every two hours i just got
um his uh prescription it was a thousand
dollars
i couldn't pay for it i'm gonna pay for
it
i know i have to go in and tell my
nine-year-old son i couldn't pay for it
i work a full-time job my husband works
a full-time job i work third shift
i go to school during the day how are
you guys making it
am i the only one struggling how are you
guys doing it
but surely there's a good reason insulin
is so expensive right
well let's take a look at the drug's
history all the way back in 1922
researchers from the university of
toronto announced the discovery of
insulin
two of the researchers dr frederick
banting and dr j.j r macleod received
the nobel prize for their work
since these two men held the patent for
insulin they stood to make an enormous
sum of money by monopolizing its
production
instead realizing the life-saving
potential of the drug banting and mcleod
sold the patent to the university for
one dollar each
to the people who say there would be no
innovation without financial incentive
here's a prime bit of evidence to the
contrary there are few things more
lucrative than medical patents
and yet these men sold the rights for
next to nothing why
because they actually cared about other
human beings and not everyone is so
perverted by the profit motive
after the patent was handed off to the
university of toronto the institution
made a grave mistake
they licensed the manufacturing of the
drug to eli lilly and novo nordisk
when the u.s gets its hands on something
it immediately ceases to be a force for
good and becomes nothing more than a way
to generate ever greater profits
and that's exactly what happened with
insulin the two pharma companies
patented their products
essentially creating a monopoly over the
life-saving drug eventually a third
company
sanofi got in on the action and today
these three companies account for 90
of the insulin market you may be
thinking okay cool so there's at least
some competition well
not really here are some graphs plotting
the price history of drugs from these
companies
notice anything the prices for their
respective drugs have increased at
exactly the same rate
not at similar rates at exactly the same
rate
that's not competition that's collusion
the insulin giants are working together
to ensure that they all make as much
money as possible
well that's horrible but surely someone
could just make a generic version of
insulin right
that would force the big three to lower
their prices in theory
sure but here's the thing about patents
if you hold a patent for a particular
drug
no one else can produce that drug for a
certain period of time when that time is
nearly up you can simply make a small
change to the formula refile the patent
and boom
you've just secured your monopoly for
another 20 years that's
exactly what the big insulin producers
have been doing and here's the absurd
part
you don't even need to improve the
product you just need to change it and
you need to be able to prove that it's
not objectively worse
patent law is completely broken and
that's part of what has allowed the
insulin giants to maintain their
stranglehold and keep inflating their
prices while americans are literally
dying over the lack of a drug that was
intended to be made available for even
the poorest people around the world
it should come as no surprise that
between 2005 and 2015
78 of drug patents were not for new
drugs but for slightly modified versions
of existing ones in order to extend
their patents
this practice paired with the fact that
the fda does not regulate drug prices
has made the us a wonderland for
exploitative corporations and predatory
institutions
the manufacturer can charge a thousand
dollars a month for insulin
a hospital can charge a hundred bucks
for a single iv bag that's worth maybe a
dollar
private insurance companies can make it
nearly impossible to find in-network
doctors
forcing you to pay absurd out-of-network
rates they can set insanely high
deductibles which will guarantee a
healthy profit for the insurance company
while threatening even financially
stable americans with bankruptcy
and of course this insurance is tied to
your employment so if you get laid off
because oh i don't know
a global pandemic that we completely
refuse to address you'll be paying out
of pocket for everything
this system is not built with the
well-being of american citizens in mind
its sole purpose is to monetize the
suffering of hundreds of millions of
people
when the profit motive is the driving
factor nothing else matters
everything is beholden to the dollar
this is why insulin is 10 times more
expensive in the us than anywhere else
this is why scumbags like martin shkreli
can raise the price of a drug by five
thousand percent overnight
it's why so many americans go bankrupt
trying to pay medical bills it's why we
die of preventable causes
it's why our sick refuse to get
treatment because they know they can't
afford it
as long as the pharmaceutical industry
is allowed to operate without oversight
they will continue to raise prices until
there's not a single american who can
afford their drugs
unlike the men who discovered insulin
the ones who peddle it today
don't care about their fellow human
beings all they care about is making
money
we need to take a look around realize
that our health care system is the worst
of any developed nation
and demand that those in power drag our
country into the 21st century
there is no reason for this amount of
suffering in the richest nation on earth
if you'd like to learn more about what a
modern egalitarian healthcare system
could look like
i highly recommend you check out
medicine of the future on
curiositystream
it's a great documentary about how
advancements in medicine could extend
the healthy lives of all people
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content and the financial security of
those who produce it
they've got thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula so we
don't have to worry about demonetization
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiositystream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100 free
for a limited time curiosity stream has
extended their holiday pricing which is
41
off their annual plan that's less than
12 bucks a year for both curiosity
stream
and nebula which in my humble opinion is
a pretty great deal
the holiday sale ends on january 31st so
be quick if you want the best price it
really is a steal
since we're all still waiting for the
vaccine why not spend some time learning
about fascinating topics on curiosity
stream or check out nebula's original
content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended
ad free there really is something for
everyone and by signing up at the link
below you're helping us produce more
content without the fear of
demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week